how's it going my name is Pierre and
welcome to another unedited vlog take a
seat
no but oh you're already sitting I'm
sorry anyway
by the time you're watching this video
I'm going to be in LA probably I might
still be on the plane
me and my ex I mentioned before me and
MRSA and burping at our dog - we're
going there to stay for a month to just
enjoy ourself and yeah it's gonna be fun
don't worry though don't worry I'm still
gonna upload videos while I'm there so
it really shouldn't like matter that
much to you bros and where I am I don't
know so I just wanted to mention that in
case you're wondering I had prepared the
Crypt man which was awesome the ending
is super good super good and I have
prepared the arrival slender the arrival
so there will be videos while I'm gone
while I'm on the plane I think maybe I
don't know but yeah it took me a lot of
time to prepare I prepared six videos
froze it takes me like months to prepare
three in advance
I did six I think I did pretty damn good
but yeah also by the time this video is
up I will be at 6 million brows problem
that is crazy
seriously I still remember the video I
made I still have it off for a hundred
subscribers and I was so pumped for a
hundred and comparing that to six
billion is I cuz a lot a lot of people
asked me like how does it feel like it
feels if it feels the same as like just
as fun as when I had fewer and
subscribers or pros or whatever so for
people who aspire to be in my position I
don't know why you would want to be but
really it's just this fun
don't don't stress yourself about being
big or anything like I have nothing this
is a good blog anyway sorry I didn't
know I just wanted to say that I know
for sure that it would not be fun to
make these videos without you bros and i
wouldn't even bother because it's thanks
to you bros that I'm having so much fun
with it I'm literally living my dream
you can go to LA I mean I don't know
what's up with that and you talk I'm
doing good so I just wanted to say thank
you bros 6 million times so I'm gonna do
it thank you thank you ok I'm tired
there's no way for me to properly say
thank you for something so amazing so
we're instead you know what we're gonna
do
haha you guessed it we're gonna head but
you ready okay okay so this is for six
million let's go for six be I oh that's
way too bit of stretch let's go for
seven how about that anyway stay awesome
bros thanks for all your support
it comes to breakfast